this is a comic which came out a couple
of weeks ago it's skcd comic turns out
the 22nd of december this year is an
event that astronomers have been looking
forward to for a very very long time and
why the hexagon for people who are
wondering so this is about the james
webb space telescope and the james webb
space telescope is made up of hexagonal
segments to its mirror so actually has
this rather beautiful kind of honeycomb
appearance to it this seems to be a
project that the launch date has moved
many times it hasn't in fact it recently
moved so it was the 18th until a couple
of weeks ago so jwst is now at the
launch site in french guiana it's
arrived there's a whole ring roll about
that they had to you know they kept very
quiet about what ship it was being
shipped in because they were nervous it
was going to get held to ransom on the
way and all sorts of things like that
but anyway finally arrived and is being
integrated onto the rocket at the
eastern launch site down there in french
guiana you want to launch them as close
to the equator as you can to kind of get
a nice kick from the earth and so there
they are quite close to the equator but
then while they were in the process of
integrating it a clamp unexpectedly
released which basically didn't quite
drop the telescope but it jerked it
in a way that the telescope was not
designed to be jerked at which point
everyone got very very nervous and they
stopped everything and they had a quick
inquiry just to make sure that actually
this wasn't going to happen again but
also to make sure nothing bad had
happened to the telescope when it was
jerked in this way turns out everything
was fine but that pushed things back
another four days so yeah we went from
the 18th to the 22nd but as you said
this is the end of another of a very
long series of delays in fact i have
another xkcd comic for you this one was
made in 2018 which is a nice plot
showing the planned launch date as a
function of when it was being planned so
way back in the 1990s for example when i
first became aware of the telescope we
were planning to launch it in about 2007
or thereabouts and you can see that as
time's gone on it's got steadily delayed
and the point of this comic back in 2018
was to point out that at least these
lines were kind of converging with each
other because ultimately you want your
launch date to be the current date and
at that point they were projecting it
would happen in about 2026. turns out
hopefully they were a bit pessimistic in
that actually in 2018 they picked on
2021 and it stayed at 2021 since then
so hopefully this line is now horizontal
and we will reach this point where the
current date and the launch date are the
same date sometime just before christmas
this year professor there's so much more
nervousness about this launch than
almost any space launch i can think of
certainly non-human ones can you help us
understand why the stakes are so high
here firstly it's a very complicated
thing it's a very expensive thing and
it's taking a very long time
if you put those three things together
people get extremely nervous about it
the long time thing people have
basically spent their entire careers
working on this telescope so actually if
it doesn't work that's their life work
down the tubes so not surprisingly
that's kind of you know that makes
people pretty nervous secondly it's a
really large sum of money it's you know
the total budget obviously as the
thing's been delayed more and more one
of the things that always goes with
delays is costs go up and up and it's
going to cost ultimately about 10
billion dollars so it's a serious
serious sum of money about it and the
final thing is that it's incredibly
complicated and when you make something
that complicated there are just a myriad
ways it can go wrong this is a blog post
from nasa so this is the official word
from nasa relatively recently this came
out i was talking about the launch of
the telescope and it says about 50
deployments need to occur we talk about
the deployments that's basically things
moving when it's up there so 50
movements need to occur after launch to
set up the huge system
with 344 so called single point failures
so firstly the deployments the movements
i remember years and years ago i showed
an animation of jwst as it was deploying
to a mate of mine who works in the
satellite industry and i could just see
the color kind of draining out of his
face as he was watching this thing
because in order to pack the thing into
the nose cone of a rocket you have to
fold it up and so once it's up there it
has to unfold with incredible accuracy
and there's all these parts need to
expand and come out and unfold correctly
and clunk into place and as each of
these things was moving i could see this
guy kind of looking paler and player and
he said to me you know in satellites we
hate moving parts
because moving parts fail
and things which work perfectly well in
a lab
you find when you put them into space
you know things vacuum weld together and
all sorts of weird things happen and
they won't move
and so we design our satellites with as
few moving parts as we can get away and
look at all these number of moving parts
you've got and then there's this 344
single point failure so basically these
are things where if something goes wrong
we think we fixed it you know we think
we've made it so it won't go wrong but
if something goes wrong it is one thing
then the thing won't work right and
and 344 is an awful lot of them and they
all have to not fail that means that if
for any one of them
if there's a one in a thousand chance
that it goes wrong so just you know
we've really fixed it if we've nailed it
down there's only a one in a thousand
chance it'll go wrong but of course they
all have to
go go that other you know 999 times out
of a thousand it'll be fine but one time
in a thousand it won't and so you have
to multiply 0.999 by 0.999 by you know
344 times so which turns out to be about
0.7
so that means that even if each one of
those there's only a one in a thousand
chance it'll go wrong
ultimately it means that there's only a
70 chance the telescope will work
now hopefully they've mitigated all
these much more than one in a thousand
chance but it shows you that actually
even if you think you've nailed and
they're just the ones they know about
right and so if there's other stuff that
people haven't even thought of you know
your unknown unknowns so that's why
people are keeping absolutely everything
crossed at this point a fourth thing
that you didn't mention that make the
stake so high is that it's totally
unfixable oh yes so the hubble space
telescope which is the kind of successor
to was really designed to work more in
the optical and the ultraviolet part of
the spectrum this is really designed to
work in the infrared for reasons we'll
come on to a little bit one of the
problems with doing infrared astronomy
is that everything glows in the infrared
and in particular the earth and the moon
glow very brightly in the infrared so
you want to get this telescope as far
away as you can from the earth and in a
way where you can actually shield it
from the earth so it never actually
looks at the earth you keep all the cold
side of it away from the earth to stop
the earth from warming it up and that
means you have to shoot it a long way
from earth so actually end up at one of
these lagrange point orbits it's the l2
of it so it's about a million miles from
the earth basically it's far too far
away for an astral ever to fix i can
understand that the people who've worked
on this and made it their life work are
feeling very nervous right now like
unspeakably nervous but what about other
astronomers like you does it give you
cold sweats or are you just kind of
watching it almost like a sports game i
wonder what way is it going to go i i
hope i have enough empathy from my
colleagues that i'm actually you know
i'm feeling for them right i i should
say i i don't have much skin in this
game right i'm not planning to use you
know it's really optimized for doing
things that on the kind of astronomy i
do for the most part so actually in that
sense i don't have a particular direct
stake in it but so much of my community
does and we've invested so much in it
that it will be completely devastating
for the community if it doesn't work so
yeah i'm i'm sweating almost as much as
they are is part of you jealous that 10
billion was spent on instrumentation
that doesn't advance your particular
niche in the field or are you big enough
to think it's for the greater good to an
extent i'm happy to say it's for the
greater good there was you know there
was a big argument in astronomy when we
were first proposing this and its budget
was growing and growing and growing and
actually in the u.s it was growing to
the extent that it was squeezing
everything else out because of course
nasa only has a certain amount of money
to spend on science and as jwst's budget
was growing and growing that was pushing
other things out
and i think there really was you know
legitimate concern in the astronomical
community at this point they're saying
we're putting all our eggs in this one
basket we're committing to do this one
thing and actually we're probably losing
out on lots of smaller things we could
be doing because there just isn't any
money to do them anymore
but obviously that you know that's that
argument has been had and won and so
actually there's no point really in
going back over that and now we've got
this you know and it truly is it's a
brilliant facility we have this
brilliant facility
we and assuming that it works we'll be
doing some truly amazing science with it
let's have a picture of it look at a
picture of it always here's the
telescope it's primary mirror this thing
is six and a half meters across which is
too big to fit into the top end of an
ariane 5 so it's going up in an area and
five launcher that's one of the main
contributions that the europeans are
making to this mission it's made up of
these hexagonal segments the individual
segments are made of beryllium which is
a really nasty material very poisonous
it's very toxic yeah nasty stuff to work
with but it's very light very rigid and
it doesn't care if you put it in very
cold temperatures so it's perfect for
this in some ways it's not going to be
as spectacular as a hubble space
telescope because it won't be seeing
kind of the optical light that that
tends to make for very spectacular
images of things it's much more kind of
red light all the way through to the
infrared and so the gold coating is
basically because gold reflects very
well all through that range of
wavelengths from the red to the infrared
this here is about the size of a tennis
court and is basically the thing that
keeps the sun off remember we said we
have to keep this telescope cold in
order for it to do its infrared
astronomy and the only way you can keep
something cold is to stop it being in
direct sunlight and so throughout its
entire lifetime this sunshade which
again obviously is enormous so i had to
unfurl is these very thin series of very
thin sheets each of which kind of gets
pulled out into this large diamond
shaped structure so when it's in orbit
the earth will be somewhere down here
and actually the sun will be down here
as well so you keep the earth out of the
way you keep the sun out of the way you
keep the moon out of the way they're
always behind this shade and obviously
then your solar array so your solar
panels are pointed that way because
that's where the sun is
and your communications stuff so there's
an antenna there that's where the earth
is as well so yes you're pointing your
communications that way but everything
this side is kind of always in shade so
basically the light comes to the front
bounces up to the secondary mirror here
bounces through a hole in the middle it
ends up in kind of the instruments which
are at the back here which are the
things that kind of record the light we
can take spectra we can make images let
me show you the optics so this is kind
of a sort of cross-sectional view this
is a three mirror design so you've got
primary secondary tertiary to that there
are three kind of main forms of image
distortion with a three mirror design to
your telescope you can kind of optimally
take out all three of those effects if
you've only got two mirrors you end up
trading one thing off against another so
you might get rid of the coma but you
get more spare collaboration but with
three mirrors you can actually design it
to really optimize it and the reason why
you have this slightly weird off-axis
design is so that off-axis actually
introduces an aberration of its own it
messes up the images but you then you
just have this tertiary mirror which has
just the right shape to take it take
those effects back out again and the
nice thing is that you can have the
light bouncing out here back through
there
off that territory mirror if it were a
beautifully symmetric design that mirror
would be kind of it right in the middle
here and it would have blocked the light
from coming in in the first place but by
kind of offsetting everything in this
way you can kind of get the mirrors out
of line with each other so that they
don't sort of all lie in each other's
light path this final fine mirror is
actually just a flat mirror and all it's
there to do is that if the pointing of
the telescope starts to wander a little
bit that kind of mirror just tilts a
little bit to bring whatever you're
looking at back to the middle so it's
just basically like image stabilization
which is what that final mirror is doing
it just will correct things and and hold
your image sharply together there are
many science goals for these things but
one of them is you know obviously to
peer further than we've ever been able
to appear before and because of the
finite like travel time when you peer
further you're looking back in time so
by peering further than we've ever been
appearing before we can look earlier and
earlier in the universe and so the hope
is we'll be able to see things so far
away that we'll actually see the first
stars forming in the universe that's a
very challenging thing to do because you
know individual stars are incredibly
famed and we want to look at an
individual star you know billions of
light years away the thing that kind of
works in our favor a little bit is it's
thought in the primordial universe all
there was was hydrogen and helium the
stuff that was made in the big bang a
little bit of lithium but basically just
hydrogen and helium no heavy elements
and when you go and solve those stellar
structure equations that tell you all
about how stars are made up what stars
are stable what stars will form if you
try and make stars with no heavy
elements in them it looks like you end
up with very massive stars and very
massive stars very bright and so that's
why we think we have standard good shot
of actually seeing those that first
generation of stars formed because we
think those first generation of stars
were very massive and very bright and so
with the james webb we'll have enough
sensitivity to pick up the individual
stars that formed now the other thing we
have to fight against is those stars
will be probably producing most of their
light kind of in the optical part of the
spectrum ultraviolet part of the
spectrum but as that light's travelled
to us the universe has been expanding so
that light gets stretched out
so that optical and ultraviolet light
that was emitted there will be the
infrared by the time it gets to the jwst
and that's why the jwst is optimized to
work in the infrared because that's
where we'll actually be able to see
these very distant objects in the
universe
i know all telescopes look back in time
but it's never felt so much like we're
looking back in time as with this this
really is you know
it's not to the beginning right and you
know the the cosmic microwave background
in uh satellites and telescopes they
really are looking back almost as far as
we can hope to see
but this is getting there right this is
really looking well beyond where we've
been able to see today just as i say see
the first star see the first galaxy so
the first collections of those stars
starting to come together to form
galaxies as well
that seems like a very specialized use
though will it have like if that that's
the primary goal will it have other uses
can other astronomers like could you
point at just a nearby galaxy you could
point it to the planet infrared tends to
be associated with cooler things
and so for example if you could use it
to look at a planetary disk forming
around a star and of course because the
other thing you gain when you've got a
big telescope is not only do you collect
more light so you can see faint things
but you make sharper images too because
the sharpness of the images you know
kind of increases as you make a
telescope twice as big the images get
twice as sharp this is a telescope
that's what almost three times as big as
the hubble space telescope so actually
we'll get images which are almost three
times as sharp and so actually we'll be
able to see planets around other stars
see planetary systems forming see the
individual planets and actually collect
enough light to split up the light
that's reflected from those individual
planets to study the properties of their
atmospheres so we'll actually be able to
learn something about the planets that
are orbiting around other stars not just
what the planet there not just image it
but actually start looking at the
properties of what light gets reflected
from that planet which tells us what its
atmosphere is made up
if it gets off the launch pad please let
it get off the launch pad
how long will we know until it's if it's
unfolded correctly and like is it a long
long way i think it's a matter of weeks
to really get it to that point yeah
where we'll know everything i mean you
know it's one of those things
there are many places it can fail some
of them will be you know before it gets
off the launch pad some of them will be
at separation for stages where it's
coming away from the from you know as
the rocket stages burn up and so on some
of it will be as it's getting to that l2
point getting it into the right orbit
some will be as it deploys once it's
there
you know there are lots of places where
people are going to be holding their
breath i think
so this is miri the mid-infrared
instrument uh this is the final flight
build this is the one that's going to go
out to nasa get integrated to the
spacecraft and be launched in about four
years time
[Music]